This is a relatively simple topic.
In fact,
any of you took any kind of high school physics,
you would have done this thing with fluids.
Okay,
so this is the subject for today,
fluid dynamics and statics.
So I'll start with a simple static problem.
We are going to take,
whenever I say fluid,
uh,
you are free to imagine water or oil.
That's it.
That's good enough example of a fluid,
one important property of the fluid,
the density.
You know,
ted by row,
density of water.
I would probably do not buy a subsequent w.
And you know what?
That's mass per unit volume for water.
That happens to be 1000 kilograms per cubic meter.
So let's not linger there.
I think that's fairly simple concert.
There's more cyber concept is the one a pressure.
Okay,
so you have the notion of a pressure.
If you're going to swimming pool and you dive down to the bottom,
you know the pressure is going up.
So what's the formal definition of pressure?
Is it a vector?
Is it a scalar?
Does it have a magnitude?
Has to have a direction.
That's what I want to explain to you so you can pick a point on the fluid there
and say the pressure there is certain sites and what do we mean by that?
We mean by that,
the following.
If you get into that fluid and you want to carve out a little space for
yourself,
you're going to make a little cube,
maybe a glass cube and you wanted to live inside that cube,
so I'm going to blow up the cube like this.
Yes,
the water is trying to push you in from all sides and compress this cube.
Therefore up to push out on the two on all the walls.
If the force you exert on this wall is some f and the area of that Wallace a,
that ratio is called a pressure.
It's pressure.
I said intensive measure of how hard the water is trying to push in.
If you don't put the cube,
that pressure is still there,
but one way to measure the pressure is to try to go in there and force the fluid
out and ask how hard does it push you
and the unit for pressure is Newton per meter square and we used another name
for that call.
The Pascal
one.
Pascal is one Newton per meter square.
Here's another example of pressure.
You have a gas,
we'll do a lot of this after the break.
That is some gas inside a cylinder.
That's the piston.
Now if the pressure of the gas and the pressure of the outside world at the
same,
there's nothing you have to do.
Assuming the piston is massless,
but if you want to increase the pressure then the gas,
you put some extra weight.
That mg we pushed down and empty divided by the area of the Piston with the
extra pressure to apply.
That's also the pressure of the gas.
That pressure
is the atmospheric pressure plus the extra weight you apply.
You might add by the area of this Piston
because atmospheric pressure is everywhere.
So when you push down on the piston here to compress the gas further,
you're adding to the atmospheric pressure.
This extra force divided by area.
Sometimes,
I mean this is called the absolute pressure and that's called the atmospheric
pressure and that's called the gauge pressure gauge pressure is the pressure on
top of atmospheric pressure or example when your car has a flat,
the bright side of it is the pressure inside the tightest,
in fact equal atmospheric pressure doesn't help you because that's the precedent
side and there's the pressure outside.
And if we want to keep your car moving,
you'd really have to increase the pressure in the tire.
And when you stick this gauge in that you've measured something 32 pounds per
square inch.
That's the gauge pressure that's in excess of the atmospheric pressure.
So you should understand that the pressure is a condition in a fluid.
And one of the important properties or pressure is that if you took a fluid and
you went to a certain height,
all points at that height have the same pressure.
And we understand that as follows.
So I go to this fluids.
I imagine in my mind a little cylindrical section off the same fluid.
Just draw a dotted line around the region and focus on that little chunk of
fluid and say,
can the person on the two sides this phase and that phase be different?
The answer is no because the pressure on the left were bigger than the pressure
on the right.
I take a cylinder of some area,
a pressure times area on the left will exceed pressure times area on the right
and therefore the fluids should move to the right,
but it's not doing anything.
It's an equilibrium and the only way that can happen as if it's pushed equally
from both sides.
So notice that the pressure on this chunk from the left point this way,
and then that chunk points that way they're trying to push it in.
So pressure cannot change at a given depth.
But let's take a cylinder that looks like this.
Remember,
this is not a real cylinder.
This is the same water in mentally have isolated a part of the water that looks
like a cylinder,
maybe want to dry it and dotted lines.
It's just a fluid of cylindrical shape.
Basically Area A and height age.
I can ask the following question.
Uh,
let's say h one is the measure of that one from the surface and h two is the
depth from the surface to be lower phase of the cylinder.
We can know,
argue the pressure on the top and bottom really should not be equal.
You should think about it by the same argument I gave earlier.
We'll tell me cannot be equal if they were equal.
Since these two ads at equal,
the forces pushing up and pushing down,
we'll cancel no net force on the cylinder.
You can ask them what's keeping the cylinder of water from falling down?
Well,
that has to be a forced to equal the weight of that cylinder.
Therefore that has to be a net upward force.
That means the pressure down here pushing up better be higher than the pressure
on the top.
We're now going to calculate what the pressure differences,
so let's call the pressure downstairs and upstairs p one.
Then the upward force is p one times a.
The downward force is p two times a day.
That's the net upward force that's got to be equal to the weight of that amount
of water
wait does found by first the mass,
which is area times h do minus h one that's the volume of the cylinder times the
density of water or whatever fluid you have.
That's the mass of the cylinder.
That's the weight of that cylinder of liquid.
All I have done is balanced the gravitational force on this cylinder with a net
upward force due to the different pressures.
I think I made one mistake here.
Uh,
upward force in magnitude.
I want to write this p two times a and downward force.
I want rate as p one.
How do you keep track of sciences?
A little subtle and balancing two magnitudes.
I'm balancing net upward force named repeat two is considered positive upward
and this is the force of gravity down and balancing the magnitudes.
So the AIDEA cancels out
because this area,
see the pressure between two points should not depend on the area of this
fictitious something that I took.
In fact,
I find it as equal to Roe g times h two minus h one which is the difference in
the depth of these two points.
Yes.
Which one?
Yeah.
In fact it nor is it really happens to be normal are perpendicular the area
because the pressure will push straight up and straight down.
How about forces on the side of the cylinder there?
Cancel it every height because at every height the push from the left and right
are equal.
I already showed you that.
So for the mechanic and stability of this chunk,
I need all forces to add up to zero horizontally.
There is no gravity and the pressure that every height is equal so that canceled
so vertically.
That is the force of gravity and just cancelled by the difference in pressure.
So we can see that p two is equal to p one plus Roy g times the height
difference
and people write this formula as follows is very standard to take p one to be
the point right at the surface and Peter to be any point inside and to call the
depth of that simply as h.
Then the pressure at the point p in the fluid is the pressure at the top,
which is usually atmospheric pressure plus row,
g,
H,
so I don't have an h one and h two because h one I've chosen to be zero and h
two I've simply calling it the say something very simple.
If you go to lake at the surface of the lake,
the pressure is due to the atmosphere.
You take a dive,
you go down some depth age,
the pressure goes up by this amount.
Now if you go to the bottom of the ocean,
it's can be incredible amount of pressure.
That's why you and I cannot survive in the bottom of yours
because the outside pressure inside pressure is usually atmospheric pressure.
You breathing the air in your lungs,
you go down with that outside of atmospheric plus this and that can kill you.
That way when you build a submarine,
you got to make sure it can withstand the pressure,
but fish don't have the problem because fish are breathing the water.
The water is going into their system and outside the system.
So that's one way for you to live for 20,000 feet under the sea.
Start drinking the water,
but it's not a longterm solution.
It'll work in the Shrock time because you'll be equalizing the pressure.
Okay.
Now how about the atmospheric pressure?
What's the origin of that?
And the origin of the atmospheric pressure is that
we had ourselves living
in a bottom of a pool,
but it's filled with air.
The air heads,
it goes on for maybe a hundred miles,
but the density decreases eventually vanishes.
So I cannot tell you precisely by the atmosphere ends.
But I can say the following,
if I go far above at the absolute pressure to zero in free space,
that is just vacuum.
The pressure here is the atmospheric pressure.
Atmospheric pressure at the bottom of the earth is equal to zero plus row g h
barrow is the density of air.
G is g and h of the height of the atmosphere.
Yeah.
And that happens to be a 10 to the five fast cows.
So we are living in a bottom of a pool where the pressure distended,
the Fi Pascal's relative to empty space,
interstellar space.
Did I say said that pressure doesn't kill us because the pressure can be felt
world from the outside pushing in and inside going through your nostrils and
everything else,
pushing out what do you have all seen the dramatic experiment where you take a
can of something and you heat it up so the ad goes out,
then you seal it.
Then the ad that's been driven out reduces the pressure.
So when you seal it and you cool it,
then the pressure drops and even the drop in pressure,
it doesn't even drop down to zero,
but it's big enough for the whole canned to implode.
No,
let's see
what you get here.
Uh,
let's do the following.
This is Roy g eight and you can ask us the following question.
If this was a swimming pool,
how high would the water be?
Another words,
what height of water above the earth will produce the same pressure as our
atmosphere?
This.
Then I say,
if I want to enter the five Pascal's,
that's the density of water.
A standard three gls pretend is 10 and eight is what I'm looking for.
Cancel all the powers of 10,
eight,
just like 10 meters.
And it turns out is the best of my knowledge is 32 feet.
This is the units,
uh,
we don't use in the book,
but it's a very common way of thinking.
32 feet.
So we added at the bottom of a pool.
If it is filled with water,
we'd be 32 feet of water.
All right,
so now we're going to take this formula p equals P,
not Roy g,
H,
n put it to work,
get some mileage out of that.
So what are the things we can do with that formula?
First thing you can do is to build yourself a barometer.
But I met her.
You know,
it's a way to tell what the pressure is today at atmospheric pressure.
When I set the standard,
the five,
that's a typical pressure.
It doesn't really stay locked in the valley each day that are fluctuations.
That's why the weather person tells you pressure's going up,
pressure's going down.
So let's find a way to measure the pressure.
And he is one way to do that.
You take a,
I can have something,
fill it with some liquid,
take a test,
you
evacuated,
completely suck all the air out of it and stick it into this.
When you do that is complete vacuum here in the atmosphere is pushing down to
the fluid,
will rise
up to some height,
age
and you can ask how high will it go?
What's going to be the height?
Well little go to a height.
So that zero pressure here plus this Roy g eight which is the pressure there
will be the same as the pressure here because they are two points at the same
height.
Pressured here is the atmospheric pressure.
So Russia here,
atmospheric pressure is zero at the top of that you listed row
g h
so if you build this gadget,
there's better meter out of water.
The water column,
we'll raise the height of 32 feet.
But no,
nobody wants to get to 32 feet high.
So what do you use instead is mercury because it's very dense so you want to get
the same atmospheric pressure,
but you want to have a bigger role and get a smaller rate.
If you go look up a book and find the density of medically,
you're going to find the height is something like,
I don't know,
seven 57 80 millimeters.
That's why the weather guy who says the pressure today so many millimeters and
the Medicare he is dropping.
No,
I'm not sure why they bothered to give the numbers because for most of us,
including me,
those numbers don't mean anything.
Here's the number seven 46 millimeters.
Does it speak to you?
Not to me.
So it
speaks to one of you guys?
Yeah.
Okay.
Some number.
It's not like saying today's in the 67 degree Fahrenheit.
At least I know what that means.
Right?
[inaudible] you hit the mercury.
I think it's just a waste of time anyway.
They are telling you how much the Medicare use.
Okay.
You can use any fluid you like.
What do you got to agree on using mercury?
Because if for seven 60 millimeters and it's watered,
the person's talking about,
of course you are in serious trouble.
So I understood,
we are talking about mercury
automatic queries using thermometers.
That's the subject for after the break.
So they're the mercury falling,
could Stanford falling temperatures and rising temperatures.
But here it is for falling pressure and rising pressure.
So this is the first gadget you can build with what I've taught you.
Next Guide did you can build is you can imagine,
uh,
this is you frank,
to drink,
uh,
this year,
years and knows and whatnot.
You've got a straw and you're trying to drink something.
Now remember the fluid is water,
okay?
It's not Medicare Reno because you're doing different experiments.
You've gone to drink from a straw.
So how do you do that?
You know,
when you drink from a straw,
you create a partial vacuum in your mouth.
So the pressure here.
So in the case of the fluid that you want a drink,
this is a
your head,
the oppression here
less than the atmosphere,
even less than the atmosphere by some amount.
Then the fluid can start climbing up to some height and claim to set to high so
that the lower pressure plus that Roy g h will equal atmospheric pressure.
So you've got to reduce the pressure and water and water in your mouth till this
fluid can play him up.
If he just,
if you wanted to just make it to your mouth,
it depends on the length of the straw,
the height,
the straw.
If you want to suck it up a certain height,
then that height,
Raji,
h,
bless the pressure in your mouth is the pressure here.
And that's the atmospheric pressure.
So if you want to drink water from a well that is more than 32 feet deep,
you're out of luck.
Because even if your face and your head or a complete vacuum,
you cannot get the water to climb more than 32 feet.
So that's another illustration of this.
So one more example of this peak goes peanut plus Roy g h is if I give you
another fluid,
it doesn't mix with water and I tell you find a density.
There are many ways.
One is to just find the mass and volume of that fluid and divide.
But here's another thing people use.
You take what's called a youtube.
Yeah,
that's not,
I know that's very post Ali embarrassing videos.
This was physics contribution to pop culture long before any of this happened.
This is the youtube,
the youtube.
Let's say you fill it up with one fluid and this is the other fluids cause this
is oil and this is water.
If the two heights were equal then you know we're talking about the same fluid
but this is supposed to tell you that oil is less dense than water and we can
check that by comparing two points in this fluid at the same height
and saying the pressure must be the same at those points.
You understand how I get that,
that pressure and that pressure that equal because you can draw a cylinder there
horizontally which cannot be pushed sideways from here to this pressure at that
broad g h in that row,
g h and you come to that point,
you conclude that pressure is also equal.
You cannot jump into the new fluid here because the role for here in the row for
this a different,
but these two points have the same pressure are in the same fluid.
So let me write that statement that this pressure and this pressure the equal by
saying atmospheric pressure is on the top for both of them.
That plus row one g h one is equal atmospheric pressure blows road to the age
too,
but this is the second fluid I it goes to h two first fluid.
The hightest equaled h one the density is a row one and row two atmospheric
pressures cancel.
Then you find each one over h two is equal to the road to overall one.
So by comparing the heights you can find the relative density.
If one of them is water then that whatever it is.
If you know the density of one fluid,
you can find the density or the other.
Okay.
Yet another application of this law that the pressure is equal at a given height
is the famous hydraulic press.
So he had his uh,
okay.
Here are two pistons of different radio.
This has got cross section 80 81 this got cross section 88 two
and here I want to put some incompressible fluid.
Yeah.
Incompressible fluid is something whose volume cannot be changed no matter how
much you press it.
The water is pretty close to incompressible.
It does have a couple of ability,
but it's not going to change very much for our purposes.
So now here I have a piston and I have a piston here and I pushed down here with
the force f one
and ask what force will I get at the other site?
You might think f one equals f two but since these fluids are at the same
height,
the only no p one equal speed to that means efan over a one is equal to f two
over eight two.
So this fluid here,
we'll push up here with the force F two which is equal to f one times eight to
or what a,
what
did I get it right?
Uh,
pardon me?
Did they make a mistake here?
That's right.
What?
I wanted to amplify the force.
So what do you really want to do?
Well,
it's a matter of who you want emphasize.
So what do you want?
Emphasize here.
Maybe if I drew a picture,
I will know exactly what I'm planning to do.
This picture is fine in practice.
This is not what you do.
You want to push down here and raised something there because what you really
imagine is some elephants,
elephants standing here and you want to lift the elephant by applying a force
here.
So let's still call your force f two in the force.
And the other side is the force.
You apply times aim one ovary too.
So it,
it went over a two could be a hundred.
What that means is if you apply one Newton here,
you'll get a hundred newtons on the other side.
So that's the way to Max to convert a small force in their log force.
But this is the oldest trick in the book,
even older one invented by cave people is that if you have a support like this,
you can put a weight here.
Yeah,
and let me see.
That's right.
So the tiny weight here can lift the big weight here because that MDF and that
distance in the same data,
this instance,
we'll be equal,
but you must know even from that example that you don't get something for
nothing.
In other words,
if you lift the elephant here,
we're pushing down here the fact that the forces don't match perfectly.
Okay,
but the work you do here must be the work delivered at the other side.
The law of conservation of energy work you do on this side is the force
multiplied by the distance.
A force multiplied by distance.
I'm going to write as a pressure,
blames the cross section eight.
Yeah,
times distance.
Okay,
but what is eight times eight?
Two Times the x two eight two times x two.
If you push the liquid here,
you moved at a distance.
Delta x two area.
Tom Del Tech's too is the volume of fluid you push down here.
That's the volume.
They'll come up on the other side.
So you're free to write that as p two times a one delta x one
okay,
but p two a one I'm sorry.
Uh,
yes,
no,
let's write.
P two is the same as p one
p one five a one is f one.
Okay,
so he just says that the force times distance on one site is the forced time
distance on the other side.
That means the work you actually do is not amplified by the process.
You cannot get more with juveniles out of one site by any device.
What you put in is what you get out.
But still it's useful because in practice you may have to move a whole meter
here to lift the elephant by one centimeter.
But the point is you can lift elephants this way.
That's the important thing.
Okay?
That's why it's worth doing.
And this is how you,
the break in your car works.
You know,
you pump the brake pedal,
that's the little cylinder there and there's a fluid there.
And the fluid is pushed by your feet and you push it quite a bit,
several centimeters at the other end.
That's another cylinder who's piston is right next to the drum is rotating and
push us on the drum and exerts an enormous amount of force.
But it moves a very tiny amount.
The shoes that grab your rotating drum move a very tiny amount,
but as your feet move a large amount,
but that's the ratio of the force that's transmitted.
The fluid has the same pressure,
the brake fluid at the same pressure with the force you apply with your feet is
much,
much smarter than the force that the drum will exert on the rotating that the
disc brakes will exert on the rotating draw.
So a lot of hydraulics is based on this simple amplification of force.
Yeah.
All right.
Now,
why move to
next topic in this field,
which is the argument,
this principle.
So we all know the conditions under which this way discovers.
I will not go into that other than to say that Mr Archimedes noticed that if you
immerse something in a fluid,
it seems to weigh less.
What I mean by that is that if you attach it to some kind of a spring balance
and you waited so that the k except the spring was the mg of the object and if
you did the same thing,
now you will find it seems to weigh less
and the question was home with less Archimedes answer is pretty simple.
The Amo and babies do you lose the weight,
the weight loss
equals the weight of liquid displaced.
Now how do you show that?
Because we don't right now so many years after argument is we will not accept
this on faith.
We want to be able to show this is the case.
There are several ways to prove this.
One way,
which I like is to say if you,
the thing is the thing you want hanging here was itself a tank of water ship
like that.
You don't have to do anything because that chunk of water can float at that
height for free.
But now if it took the chunk of water and put a stone here,
have the same shape,
the rest of the fluid doesn't know what you're doing.
It applies the same force that it would do its own colleagues.
Emily,
this is water.
That's the water is in a configuration ready to support that amount of water.
If you took that water out and put something in the water,
we'll apply the same amount of force and the rest of it is your problem.
You will play the remaining force so the water is ready to support it's own kind
of any volume.
That's the meaning of being an equilibrium.
Any chunk of water is an equilibrium,
therefore it's getting an upward force equal to the weight.
What we're saying is if without disturbing the environment,
you take the water out and put something in its place,
the rest of the guys will apply the same force.
Now one formal way to prove that you can take various geometries,
but I prefer a cylindrical geometry,
so this is in this example,
not a piece of water,
but the new material live introduced inside the water and we want to find the
buoyancy force.
What is the net force of volumes,
but it's the pressure at the bottom times the ATO
minus pressure that the top times the area it is seeing the difference in the
pressure is Roy g h a but eight just now this hike,
well eight [inaudible] say is the volume of the water road times that is the
weight of the water is the mass of the water.
At that time,
GE is the way that the liquid displaced.
You can put this for a cylinder,
you can prove this for our odd ball shapes by thinking a little harder,
but this is good enough.
So basically the body weighs less than water because the lower part of the body
is being pushed up harder than the upper part of the body is being pushed down
because the pressure increases with depth.
That's it.
That's the why you get this result from Archimedes.
No,
yet be a little careful,
uh,
on writing the equation because if this was made of a material like iron,
then the density of iron is less than,
it's more than the density of water.
So the weight of that chunk of iron will be more than the weight of the water
displaced.
So you will have to provide a net force and you can support it with the cable.
But suppose this was not
made of iron but made of Cork.
If it's Karch,
it one wanted to be there,
right,
because then the applied force by the water is more than the weight.
It takes the support.
It's the Clark will then Baba to the surface.
It don't look like this.
If you want to keep it Douglas like rubber Ducky,
you want to keep the rug Roberta key inside the water level.
You've got to pull it down or do you want it tight to the,
I think one of the problems they gave you as somebody tied this piece of
whatever to the floor,
then it'll stay but things will Bob up to the surface and the question is how
far up will it go?
We know part of it is going to be insight and part of it is going to be outside
and you can ask how much will be outside,
how much would it be insight?
You can already guess the answer,
but let's prove it.
Let FB the fraction
immersed
fractional volume in Merced.
Then we can say the weight of the liquid displaced is equal.
The factional volume times a row time,
g times the total volume
is the role of water.
Do you understand?
This is the,
this is the weight of water equaled the full volume.
This is the fraction of water displaced,
so this is simply the weight of this shaded region here and that is going to be
equal to the weight of the thing that's floating.
That is a row g times full value.
If you can,
so the g and you canceled the volume,
you find that the fraction that is immersed is the density of the material
divided by the density of water.
In other words,
if this material is 90% the density of water,
maybe emir spent 90%
that's exactly what happens with ice.
As you all know,
ice has a smaller density than water.
One of the great mysteries.
Normally when you call,
something condenses and reduces in volume and the density will go up,
but ice actually expands when you cool it.
That's where density of ice is less than the density of your water.
That's where ice floats
on water.
That's the reason icebergs
look like this because a big part of the iceberg,
that's a very peculiar property of ice.
That's the way you,
yeah,
there's movies like the titanic ready gotta he would ice thing and just
floating.
First of all,
you've density advice more than density of water.
These two actors would still be alive.
Okay?
What happens is,
uh,
it is floating.
And not only that,
what you see is maybe a small fraction of the whole thing.
That's why the big ship went down.
Okay?
But it's all thanks to this accident of nature that he had his one substance,
which been called increases.
It decreases the density.
All right?
No argument is principled.
Got Hundreds of applications.
If you want to build a board,
yes.
Have we build a book?
Here's a steel board.
Now you cannot come to me and say,
how do you make a steel boat float in water?
Okay?
It's not a solid steel board.
Okay.
If you're thinking about a solid steel boat,
you'd get in another line of work.
This is this thing made out of steel,
but it's completely hollow.
So what we claim is this,
I'm on the water weighs the same amount as that amount of see the shaded region,
so you can easily calculate how deep this one once to sync the balance.
It's week,
right?
That I assume you know how to do that.
Take this to be a rectangular boat,
cross sections,
rectangular.
It's gone down to a depth row and do it that age.
I let a,
therefore the volume of water displaced is eight times the area of the boat,
cross sectional area of the Florida,
the board,
that's the volume of water.
That's the mass of water.
That's the weight of water.
That's the weight of the boat.
If be telling me how many times do it both ways and you give me any of the base
and g and density of water.
I'll tell you what height it'll sync.
Then of course you can load more and more cargo in this.
You know,
if you have a pop here,
start putting more and more cargo.
There's some go down until the board looks like this
and that's as fun as you can push it.
That's the kind of simple calculation you wouldn't be asked.
How much cargo can that boat take?
Well,
that's very simple.
Weight of the board plus weight of the cargo is maximal in this critical
situation when they're just about to go under.
Therefore the total volume of water displaced times the density at IMG will be
the weight of your board plus cargo.
These are all elementary applications and they come from two principles.
One is the pressure increases with depth.
The second is that the weight of the liquid displaced is the weight of the,
it's a big reduction in weight,
so you can imagine three cases,
one where the density of the material is more than density of water.
In which case it will start going down and you will have to hold it up with the
cable,
but you wouldn't have to apply the same force as you would outside.
Second example is when the density of the object is less than the density of
water,
in which case it'll float with a certain fraction of it emerged in a certain
fraction of it outside the fraction they merged as simply the same fraction as
what you get by dividing its density by the density of water.
What's the density of water changes in the Dead Sea?
Because of the salt concentration density is a lot higher,
so it's a lot easier people to float.
Okay,
well for the last and final topic,
uh,
that's called Bernoulli's equation.
This is the first time I'm going to consider fluids in motion.
So far my fluids were at rest and this really pretty simple,
but nor does one more time.
All I ever invoked was Newton's law of motion.
You realize that I just took this fluid and that fluid balance the forces and
said that should be no acceleration.
If I can convince you of the one thing I have accomplished,
something to realize that all the mechanics we have done that's not appeal to
any other law than f equals m a in all these problems that we Librium a is zero
f is zero just from that fact and cloud applications have f equals Amy for
example is a very collaborative thing of a piece of the water and demand that it
be an equilibrium.
That's what we find how the pressure varies with that
but there's no new principals so far.
In fact there's got to be no new principals at all.
This term middle activity was different.
The old space time and modified but non the linguistic mechanics.
It's all coming from Newton's law as is this problem.
So we are going to describe for the first time fluid motion.
We're going to take the most general case of fluid motion but there's water in
some pipe.
This is the most famous picture in all the textbooks.
We have not thought of a better picture now and all working on it.
This is all we can come up with after 300 years water flowing in a pipe.
This point is going to be called one.
This point is going to be called to
everything.
Here we'll have a subscript one.
That means measure it from some ground.
This at the height,
each one that an h to the velocity of the fluid.
Here is some B one over the last year of the fluid there is v two
and is the density of the fluid and that's not valuable.
So imagine now a steady flow of some fluid through a pipe whose area of cross
section is changing and the overall altitude results or change.
You can have a huge tie,
you know,
pipe in the basement,
but the whole supply to the house comes brantas hours in the little pipes.
Maybe this could be the pipe in the attic,
small cross section,
possibly at a bigger height,
doesn't matter.
But we're not considering pipes that break up into four or five pipe.
This is a single pipe.
So here's the first law that you have to satisfy.
If the fluid is incompressible,
that's a certain law and we're going to talk about that law.
That's called the equation of continuity.
It relates the area here
and the velocity here to the Ada.
Hidden never lasted here and the relationship should not surprise you.
The basic premise is going to be you're shopping in water from the left and the
water cannot pile up between here and here because it incompressible.
Let me send that volume.
You can only pack in so much water,
so what comes in has to go out.
It follows that it's got to go out much faster here because the area is small
and what's the relation?
You can almost guess it,
but let's prove that.
How much water do you think comes in through this phase?
If you wait one second,
can you visualize in your mind that in one second a certain amount of fluid
comes in maybe until that point and the cross section of that fluid is a,
the distance it travels is v,
so the volume of the fluid coming in from the left,
it's really a one B one that's called the flow rate
coming in.
That's got to flow out and that's a flow rate great outside,
so if incompressible fluid,
if I tell you the flow rate at one point I've told you the Florida everywhere,
think of cars going down a freeway and the freeway's getting narrow.
Unlike in real life,
we don't allow the cars to pile up.
You want the density of cars to be the same.
That means if there's a narrow road,
they got to go faster.
The maintain the traffic that follows.
Then it follows that.
If I go to one check point and see how many cars crossed me per second here,
say a number,
we'll cross anywhere else,
but the speeds will be in inverse proportion to the area so that the product
remains the same.
Oh,
let me show this to you another way.
It's going to be helpful.
Let me wait a small time.
Delta t in a small time,
Delta t,
this front that was here would advance there.
It'll go distance be one time that Delta t
or the other end.
This front will advance the distance be two times t,
not the volume that got pushed in the time.
Delta t,
a m One v one delta t and that's the volume that came out on the other side and
you can cancel the Delta t's and come up with the result I gave you,
so wait a short time,
see what comes into the left face and see what goes out of the right face and
equate them.
Okay.
Now we are going to find a constraint between the state of the fluid here in the
state of the fluid there.
What I'm going to do,
look,
think about what's going to happen before you drive any formula supports.
You're going up hill.
Does it make sense to you that when the fluid claims uphill,
it's going to slow down?
It will slow down on the way to the top because it's got to work against
gravity.
Even if you threw a rock up there,
it's going to go up and slow down.
Therefore there's going to be some connection between the gain in height and the
velocity of the fluid
gets from the law of conservation of energy.
That's all I'm going to do.
Here's what I'm going to do you remember if there are no external forces on a
system,
kinetic was potential is kinetic plus potential.
If there are external forces on a system,
kinetic plus potential after minus candidate plus potential before it's the work
done by external forces.
That's what I'm going to use here.
What are the external forces and what's the energy is what I'm going to think
about.
So here's what I'm going to focus on.
Take this region of fluid trapped between these two cross sections at t equals
zero weight or short time Delta t.
What happens to that body of fluid?
It does what I told you in the front.
It advances the new region there.
Maybe I should draw better.
Fix it.
He had,
this is the
advance of the rear guard and in the front,
the fluid that used to terminate here has gone up to there.
In other words,
if I colored this fluid,
just this part of the fluid between here and here,
different color from the rest of the fluid,
short time later that colored liquid will be occupying this new volume.
It's the same new medical volume,
but it's a slightly different volume.
I'm going to compare the energy of this chunk of fluid before and after.
Okay.
You realize that in that comparison,
this written in between the shaded regions as common to both the chunks of fluid
point wise,
the fluid is the same location going at the same velocity,
so I don't have to worry about that.
That's common too.
Before and after.
The only difference between final minus is the energy contained in that region
minus the energy contained in this region.
That stuff it like here it was part of the old fluid is part of the new fluid.
It's at the same height going at the same speed so you don't have to worry about
it.
So what's the volume?
What's the energy of this region?
Energy is going to be row
times a two times delta x to
Delta x two is the distance it advanced here.
That's the volume of the fluid.
That's a massive of fluid.
I'm sorry that time Ge is the mass of the fluid
and the kinetic energy will be mass times B squared over two
but initial learn you will be,
I'm sorry,
am I doing something right?
Uh,
I think I made a mistake.
Sorry about that.
That is no g here.
Let me do it more slowly.
What's the mass of the shaded region?
It's got a base a too.
It's got a height.
Delta x two that's a volume time density is the mass NV squared over two is that
kinetic energy?
Potential energy would be the same mass times g h
or I should call it g h two
yup.
Oh,
you're worried about the height varying over the tube.
Yeah,
we are neglecting that aspect.
That's an important point you can ask.
When you say h two are you talking about the middle or the end and so on.
But we are going to be dealing with problems where the height differences are
much bigger than the cross section of the pipe.
So we don't worry about that.
Okay.
Now what does the same quantity here it's going to be minus row a one delta x
one Times v One square over two plus road times g h one.
That's a final energy minus initial energy.
That's got to be equal to the work done.
Now who is doing the work on this
and you guys understand where is the work coming from?
Yep.
Ah,
no gravity.
You don't count as a forest when you have a potential energy for gravity.
So gravity is included with the,
the right row g,
H or MGH.
You don't count gravity again.
Oh the foods that
right.
But if I'm looking at the fluid in question,
who is acting on that fluid?
Not what it's doing to others.
Who are the others doing something to this fluid?
Yup.
Or the walls.
Water.
The pipe will apply a normal force and that will not do any work.
Okay?
Yes.
Yep.
For water.
Yeah,
but that person is somewhere here.
But remember in mechanics,
you don't have to go to people in remote places.
I've told you when you play Newton's law,
the only kinds of forces or what you remember from day one contact forces except
for gravity,
which reaches out and grabs everything.
We've included gravity.
Who is this body of fluid in contact with?
Yes.
This fluid in between.
No,
but I'm talking about this fluid.
I'm talking about all of this fluid.
My taking,
the difference of that shared in that shaded region was a convenience,
but I'm looking at the energy change in all of this fluid.
Yeah,
but the point is the fluid to the left here is pushing it and it is pushing the
fluid to the right.
Okay.
That's the only way it is true.
There's a pump somewhere pushing the fluid in the beginning,
but you don't have to go all the way to the pump in the end.
You only ask who is in contact with me.
Well,
it's the guys to the left so they will exert a force p one times a one times
delta x one
because that's the force.
That's the distance.
That's the work done on the fluid and the work done by the fluid is p to a to
delta x tooth because if it most of the right it is doing work on the left,
it has has work done on it.
There you go.
Oh,
you can see that everyone delta x one and a two delta x two are all equal
because that is just the volume of the fluid displaced in the short time that
it's just the continuity equation.
If you divide everything by Delta t if you like,
then you will find that delta x over Delta t is v two I'm just using the fact a
when we,
when is eight to be too,
so if you cancel those factors,
what do I get?
I'm going to just write it for you now.
You guys can go home and check it.
He one minus p two is equal to one half row
B Two Square Roy,
g h two minus one half row v One square minus Roy g h one this is nice.
This is a derivation that you can go home and study at leisure.
In any book you're like,
they're all the same.
The story is the same.
I can only tell you if you'd like to know what the trick behind the derivation
was.
I don't mind going over that because maybe there are different volumes and
questions.
You may have gotten confused,
but first let me write down the result by writing everything with one on one
side and two on the other side.
I get this result.
P one was Rovy when square over to Roy g h one
is Pete to the steroid,
g h two plus one half row B two square.
This is nothing other than the law of conservation of energy applied to unit
volume.
If you take one meter cubed of the fluid,
it's masters at all times one,
so this is really a mass of one cubic meter of the fluid.
This is kinetic energy.
That's is potential energy.
That's the candidate.
That's a potential.
You mentioned,
why aren't we just created candidate plus potential to kinetic plus potential is
because this chunk of fluid that I focused on,
it's not an isolated system is getting pushed from people behind it and it's
pushing people.
I had a fit,
so you've got to take the difference between the work done on it and the work
done by it.
Then you will find they don't quite canceled because the pressures are not
equal.
The pressures that unequal you get an extra contribution,
but this is simply the law of conservation of energy.
I got it by writing law of conservation of energy,
but it takes a while for you guys to get used to applying the law of
conservation of energy.
Maybe always used to saying kinetic plus potential is kinetic potential.
You got used to that.
Are you all set a member candidate plus potential may be less at the end than
the beginning because there was friction.
This is yet another thing where there's no friction,
but that are external forces acting on a body that is gravity,
which has included the military,
right,
or potential energy MGH.
That's a waltz too.
I think some of you brought up a very good point.
The ones that are exerting a force,
but that's perpendicular to the fluid in a real fluid.
The Walsall in fact exerting force paddle to the fluid as called viscosity,
so in a real fluid that will be a drag on the fluid because the fluid really
doesn't like to move right up against the wall.
It doesn't mind moving in the middle of the tubes.
I should go near the edge.
Just the speed of the fluid will relax to zero and that's a region where there's
a lot of dissipation,
so we had ignoring what's called viscosity that ignoring all other losses.
Then this is simply law of conservation of energy and as to what I did with
those two volumes,
maybe I'll repeat this so you can all follow this.
I'm saying take all that fluid now.
Find the total energy in it and ask what happened at that fluid a little later.
Well,
fortunately here the pipe also had
some problems.
Uh,
okay,
where is this fluid?
A short time later,
I want you to think about it.
This end has moved here.
This end has moved there.
So the fluid at the end of the day is sitting there.
I want the energy of all of these guys might as the energy,
all of this.
Then you can see in the comparison is only this part that is gained in this spot
that is lost.
This part is common.
When I say common,
not only is the mass comm and the location at every location,
the height and velocity or the same.
So in this,
in the subtraction,
this will cancel that,
that'll cancel that.
This will have nothing to cancel it.
This will have nothing to cancel.
So you just focus on the relative increments and that difference is what gives
you the net change in energy and you equate that to the work done.
Okay,
so now we are going to learn how to use this Bernoulli.
The main thing to notice about Bertolli is for a minute,
if you focus on fluid at the same height,
just think about the same height.
It tells you when over the fluid picks up speed is going to lose pressure
because PE plus v squared or something is people as B squared afterwards.
If you increase be,
if you increase via gonna decrease P and that's the trust or Bernoulli at a
qualitative level.
I'll give you some quantitative examples.
So one example is that baseball,
here's the baseball coursing through air.
If you like,
you can sit and write with a baseball and say the ad is going backwards
in the baseball is going that way.
Now suppose you spin the baseball like this.
Okay?
If you spend the baseball,
it carries some of its own air due to friction between the leather and the air.
So that velocity is countered with the velocity of the drift.
You on the top and additive in the bottom.
So the actual add velocity in the bottom,
we'll be more than the bottom and less than the top because it's subtracting
this vector from the top and adding the spectrum.
The bottom.
So if the velocity is different,
this is the higher velocity region,
this the Lord will last region suppressor here.
It will be less than the pressure there.
So the bottle will sink down
the spine of the opposite.
We had the bottle will rise up.
If you spend the ball side to side,
the ball will curve from left to right.
So that's the spin on the ball.
You've got to spin the ball and release it then produces extra forces.
This rising and falling is on top of the falling due to gravity.
Even in a planet with the gravity,
you will have this extra force is coming simply because the velocity of the top
and bottom had been modified.
Here's another example.
Here's an airplane.
Wing.
Plane is going like this.
They'll go right with the plane in which gets the air seems to be doing this
far from the plane.
Everything looks the same.
I said the wing but not there,
but near the wing.
This is the flow of air pass the wing.
Notice that these guys [inaudible] have to travel further than the particles
below the wing so they can catch up here.
Everything is the same,
so the velocity on top of the air foil is faster.
That for pressure,
this lower pressures lower than in the bottom.
Then the difference in pressure times area of the wing will push the wing up.
That's the lift you get when you start a plane.
When you're on the runway.
This is why the plane goes up.
Once you're airborne,
you can tilt your wing.
When you tilt your wing to this angle,
then of course it's very clear that you can get a component of lift,
but I'm talking about when the wing is not tilted but horizontal.
That's what gives you the lift.
Now,
what if you
made a wing that looks like this?
Okay,
shit all laughing,
but this has to use to have you seen it anywhere?
Yes.
Mass car on the racetrack.
You want the opposite effect because you want to push down on the car and
therefore you manufactured wings and go to the factory where by mistake they
built a wing that looks like this.
Then you can bring it to your race car and attach it.
Then it'll keep the race card.
Now of course,
you also have the other option of going to the wing and tipping it over and and
applying it to the airplane.
But if it did not occur to you,
if you thought,
once the thing is made like this,
I'm stuck with this wing,
I'll go take it to your race car and attach it.
That'll push it down because you want to get traction so you can get the upward
lift or the downward lit.
Now it turns out this lift theory is actually somewhat naive,
and I believed it for a long time.
Now I know the story is more complicated.
That is a lot of truth to this,
but it's not the whole story.
So if you go into aeronautical engineering one day,
you will find out that it's a little more complicated reason,
way to calculate the precise lift.
But this general notion that when the air moves fast,
it loses pressure.
It is true.
So,
uh,
here's another example.
If you have an atomizer,
you know you have a perfume here and you've got a pump and then you have a cube
here.
When you squeeze the pump,
the instant you squeeze the pump,
you're driving a lot of ad here and high velocity.
Where does the Ed here is addressed?
So high velocity air has a lower pressure than Lowville on CBR.
Therefore it'll suck the perfume and spray it right on your face.
Yes.
Okay,
very good.
You know I've taught you so many things,
planets and Supernova and galaxies,
but now I got a rise out of this class.
They said,
now we are telling us something use.
All right,
so now I'm going to do two problems where I really start putting numbers in.
This is very qualitative.
I'm going to do quantitative problems and there only two kinds.
So when we are done,
we're done.
Here's a tank of water
and I poke a hole in this.
Somebody to here
at the depths,
let's call it eight
question is how fast will the water come out of here?
Turn Sour.
Do you can use this bed knollies whether this called Bernoulli's equation can
use Bernoulli to derive,
you just have to pick the points one and two cleverly to,
this is going to be 0.1.
This is going to be point to
point to in fact it just outside that whole,
what does Bernoulli say?
P One which is atmospheric pressure plus one half row.
The one square plus Roy g h one is equal but p two plus one half Roe v two
square foot.
That's Roy g h two.
Let's modify this as follows.
Ah,
let's bit pick eight store to be zero than h one is just this.
I mean you can pick the zero anywhere you like so bad.
The whole list.
I'm calling zero so I don't have to worry about this one.
V Two is what I'm after.
What about p one and p Two p one is atmospheric pressure there and right outside
the home it's also the atmospheric pressure.
So p one and p two you canceled because they both equal atmospheric pressure.
Yeah.
How about the velocity here?
You know that if you punk punch a hole in the tank and you drain it,
it's going to start moving down,
but we are going to imagine that's a huge tank,
no 10 meters diameter and this is a tiny pinprick.
Then this velocity is negligible.
You can put that back in if you like.
I'm just going to ignore that for now.
That tells me g h one let's go to one half row v two square.
Cancel the row and you find v squared is equal to two G H S.
O.
B.
Two squared is two g h.
Now you remember this formula from day one.
This is the velocity droplet would have if it spilled over the top and fell
straight down.
Okay,
because that is just the MGH being converted to one half Mv Square
because by the law of conservation of energy,
the minute the fluid starts coming out of here and draining or the top,
I have traded droplets of water at the top four droplets of water at the bottom.
Therefore,
since they had potential energy at the top,
they must have kinetic energy at the bottom,
but be clear about one thing that drop coming here.
It's not the same drop moving at the top.
If I push it over the top,
that would be the same drop and it's very clear all of this.
The beauty of this is this water is pushing down and something's coming out
here.
It's coming out with the right speed so that drop by drop the kinetic energy of
what comes out here,
the potential energy of what's draining at the top
so you can point the whole at various places.
You know,
once you punch a hole here,
it's going to land there and you can imagine the fun you can have with this kind
of problem.
Where do at points the whole so that if my dog is standing here,
it's going to feed the dog are don't feed the dog,
go up in front of the dog,
go past the dog,
get the biggest rain,
smallest rain,
whole bunch of problems.
They will combine this Bernoulli who will tell you how fast it's coming out with
chapter one of how to do trajectories once the fluid is coming or this way.
Okay,
last topic.
It's again,
it's not even a new topic.
Last application of Bertolli has to do with the
what's called the eventually meet her.
By the way,
you can imagine this is just a cross section of possible applications of fluid
dynamics,
lips.
You can take a whole course on fluid dynamics,
so let's take the falling problem.
So you had going in an airplane
and you want to find out how fast the plane is going,
how do you think you find out?
I will show you now one device people use to find the flow rate to find the
speed of the plane through the atmosphere.
So you go to the plane and
okay,
you would attest the following device to the underside of the plane.
Melissa,
I'm imagining in my mind a symmetric thing.
This is a pipe with their construction.
He had the ad is coming in at the speed of the plan itself.
See in real life the plane is going through the airport.
Go sit with the plane because the ad is going backwards at the speed of the
plane,
so that's a cross section.
A one here.
The one is what we are trying to find.
I hope you understand.
That's our goal.
Then it comes to this region where it has to speed up because able and me one is
eight to be too.
If it speeds up,
the pressure to here is going to be lower.
Let's first calculate the pressure difference between this point and this point.
No,
they had both at the same altitude.
Here's another example.
You have 5,000 feet above the ground.
Don't worry about altitude to here or there or there.
That's python is the big height in that the age cancels on both sides.
We don't worry about the variation in height over this gadget was a very,
very tiny thing.
You attached to the underside of the plane.
So then I can say p one plus one half row B one square plus Roy g h one I'm not
going to write because h one and a steward going to be equal.
Then it's beat to one half row
v two squared
that for p two minus p one
is equal to one half row B one square
minus v two square.
No B one is the speed of the plane.
No v two is not the speed of the plane,
but we know what v two is because v two times eight to is it going to be one
times 81 so we can write here one half row.
The one square minus V two squared is B one squared at times a one
over a two square.
So pull out the V one and you write it as one half row.
You want to squared times one minus a one over 82 square.
So let's digest this formula for the second.
In this problem,
everyone is bigger than eight two so you may worry that one minus 81 over 82
squared is negative.
But so is p two minus p one because p two here is certainly going to be lower
than p one here.
So you feel happier.
You can flip it backwards and write p one minus p two is something you see that
you can flip it over.
You flip it over here,
but ask yourself what do I need to know to find the speed of the plane?
Speed of the plane is here.
Roy is the density of what can you tell me Roy's density of what?
A residency of air a one and a two are known because you designed the tube.
So if you can find the pressure difference somehow you can read up the speed of
the plane.
So what people do to find the pressure difference is they go and they take,
they punch a hole there and they put here,
okay,
okay.
A fluid
like oil.
If the plane is not moving,
you can tell these two heights must be equal
because that's the condition.
But a hydrostatic equilibrium because these two pressures are equal.
But if the plane starts moving and the pressure is lower than the pressure here,
imagine this is a high pressure.
There's no pressure will push the fluid up and it'll start looking like this
with a little extra on the other side.
And how much extra is it?
Well,
let's think about it.
The pressure,
these two points is the same depression.
Here is what I call [inaudible].
The pressure here is p two less row,
g times height of this fluid.
This Roy is not the density of air.
This Roy is the density of oil.
Let's see.
Okay,
so the minute the plane begins to move,
the pressure here will be higher than the pressure here.
The fluid will be pushed up and the difference in these two heights directly is
a measurement of the pressure difference that internists a measured of the
velocity.
So what you will try to do is then forget all about the height,
the prunes.
And if you're clever enough you can put markings so that by counting the
difference in the markings,
you can translate to the speed of the plane.
You can also use this to find this rated with oil is flowing,
that was oil is flowing in a pipe and you want to know the rate at which oil is
flowing.
Again,
create a constriction in the flow,
then put some tubes.
These cannot be oil.
This gotta be some other fluid.
Once again,
that'll be a pressure difference.
And then the height difference of night different,
you can find the rate at which the fluid is flowing here.
So what's the trick we use?
Yes,
yes.
Oh,
for this one?
Yeah,
in general.
Well,
I don't,
I think all I'm,
as far as I can tell,
there's going to be a pressure difference.
There's going to translate into height difference.
And if the two do not mix,
I don't know what the danger,
I think one danger you may have is if the fluid comes in here and if we can
penetrate this,
it'll start mixing.
Right?
So for that purpose,
it may be better if this one is a higher density than the one on the top.
Now in practice,
I'm not really sure what kind of fluids people use
in any engineering thing.
Um,
my,
I get very shaky when you started going into the real worlds had been my
practice to avoid it as much as possible,
which is why I chose this career.
But people who really want to build something,
have to worry about what fluid to use.
You know,
what starts mixing,
what does makes,
what's the accuracy.
So I don't,
if I thought hard about it,
I will try to reduce everything to Newton's laws or something,
lots of thermodynamics,
but to take years and years to go from there to something practical.
So I don't know in practice what fluids people use.
So this is another example of uh,
Bernoulli's principle final one,
which is kind of problem you sometimes do get,
I'm not going to write the equations,
do the numbers,
but I'll tell you how to think about it.
Suppose you have a tank of water
and I make up another tube here and I cap it and the fluid here comes to some
height.
First question you can ask is what's the height to which fluid will rise here?
Or you know,
from your high school days he'll rise to the same height.
But what's the argument that you will give today?
But why that high tends to be the same.
You will use Bernoulli's principle and you will take two points here.
What example?
Luckily there's no velocity to what he bought additional height to worry about.
So p one equals p two which is what we did use by other considerations.
Those pressures that equal that is atmospheric pressure.
That's atmospheric pressure.
Then these columns have to be equal because starting with atmosphere plus road g
eight you want to hit the same number here as there,
okay?
But now if you open this fight and let the fluid really start flowing,
then the story is different.
The minute fluids stops flowing here starts flowing.
You amendment from the Bernoulli.
If you got a velocity,
you lose pressure.
Pressured here will be lower than the atmosphere and then this will drop.
He drops of that atmosphere.
Plus that highest gives the pressure here.
Whereas atmosphere plus the bigger height gives the pressure here
and the last you hear us,
you have to be negligible in the last here to some [inaudible] of fluids coming
up.
Okay,
so guys have a good holiday in spite of what I've done to you most reluctantly,
and I'll see you all after the break.